Continuing in al-Wajeez fi kitab
al-tahara.
In al-Wajeez in the book of
purification.
The first chapter
that the author is going to mention in
this book,
which is the book
of purification. So, this book is going
to speak about two things, right?
Purification of the
Who was here yesterday?
Come on.
Two things. Purification of
More more general than that.
No.
Purification
al-tahara min al-najasat
[Arabic recitation]
Right?
Purification
of the clothes, the body, the place of
salah. Purification from filth.
And purification
from a spiritual impurity, which is
al-hadath. Right? Which prevents a
person from making salah.
And so that is going to include wudu,
ghusl, and tayammum.
So one is going to include wudu, ghusl,
tayammum, all of that purification.
The second, it's going to include
purification of the body, the clothing,
and the place of salah. Right?
So it's two purifications, kitab
al-tahara.
It is going to speak about purification
from
the different types of filth, and it's
going to speak about purification
from al-hadath, right? Spiritual
impurity
that
we will discuss. And both of these
things,
both of these types of purification,
are primarily
obtained and primarily acquired by way
of water.
Water is the
main
thing that is used for both
types of purification. So it's only
appropriate that the first chapter is
going to be kitab
bab al-miyah.
The
chapter regarding
water. And really it's
usually referenced in the books of fiqh
as al-miyah.
[Arabic recitation]
It is jam' al-jins.
So it is actually plural. The different
types of water, right? Because water is
different types.
Which we will get into in sha Allah.
So,
in order for me to purify something from
filth, in order for me to purify myself
from sexual impurity
or hadath al-asghar, right? I need
water.
So, what is the essential
default state of water?
What is the default state of water?
[Silence]
He says, "The general principle,
general rule,
the default state
of any water
that comes down from above
or comes out of the earth naturally,
that it is considered to be purifying."
Notice the wording.
It's not just pure,
it's pure in itself and it purifies
else.
Okay?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
he says in
verse number 48 of Surat al-Furqan, and
we have sent down
from above
a purifying water.
Allah uses this word tahura,
purifying water.
Meaning it's pure in itself, and it can
be used to purify all else.
Now, that's the only evidence he
mentions.
Remember the ruling that he gave us,
the author,
the ruling he gave us
was that any water that comes down from
above,
or any water that
springs from the earth
is pure and purifying.
But then he mentions evidence for one of
those.
And that is the statement of Allah that
we have sent down from above
purifying water.
So, does this here contain the evidence
for what springs from the earth?
No.
Where did the water that's inside the
earth come from?
There we go, right?
No matter
how long it's been in there, it's all
originated from from above.
[Silence]
He says,
"And
another evidence for this ruling
is the statement of the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
when asked about the purity of the water
of the sea, sea water."
So, the story behind this narration
is there were a few companions
and
very likely this happened the animal
food
in the year of visitors,
right? Which was
the last year of the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's life in
Medina. People were coming from all over
the known world to meet Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam to pledge
their allegiance.
And so,
a group of companions asked him
that sometimes that we are fishermen
by trade. They're either fishermen or
merchants, but they spent most of their
time on the sea.
They said, "We we carry water with
us.
But the thing is is that if we use this
water to make wudu,
we are thirsty.
If we use this water to make wudu,
we will subject ourselves to thirst cuz,
you know, we only have a finite amount
of water.
very limited amount of water.
So, is it permissible for us to make
wudu
using the sea's water?"
And the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, he gave them extra. He didn't
just answer their question. He could
have said, "Yes."
But knowing that if this is something
that they are unclear about,
then
the second ruling he gives them, they're
most certainly going to be unclear
about. So, he answers them. He says,
"Huwa al-bahru
at-tahuru
ma'uhu.
Ya'ni ma'ul bahri tahirun fi nafsihi
mutahhirun li ghayrihi.
Al-hillu
[Arabic recitation]
is pure in itself and purifying.
And it's dead
is pure
and permissible.
It's dead is pure and permissible.
so, these folks were unclear if sea
water was going to be
acceptable
to make wudu.
Now,
if they read in the Quran that Allah has
prohibited
dead animals,
then they're definitely
not going to imagine
that the the ocean or the sea
that the dead carcasses or the dead fish
in the sea are going to be permissible.
And when a person is a fisherman,
they use nets, perhaps they cast nets,
or perhaps crab
they catch crabs or lobster.
crabs and lobster, you use cages that
you
drop into the
sea bed. And you pull them up later. You
come back day later, 5 days later, a
week later. It's a trap.
And so, when you go out there and you
pull these
baskets out or you pull these
nets out, invariably, part of your
catch is going to be what?
Dead. They've already died.
Right?
Fish that are already dead, crab that
crabs that are already dead, etc.
So, this is not to be discarded
because this is as well
pure.
So, the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam tells them
that the sea water, the sea's water
is purifying
and its
dead
is permissible.
Permissible meaning permissible to eat.
From this narration,
the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
tells us and the companions understood
that anything that resides in the ocean
or the sea,
no matter how it looks
or no matter its state of life,
when caught
is permissible to eat.
And I say the companions understood this
because even if we find the dead fish on
land,
it is still permissible to eat.
There's a
a story in Sahih al-Bukhari and Sahih
Muslim
where the companions radiyallahu anhum
were sent by the prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam to a battle.
And they had such little resources. This
was in the early days of Medina.
To the point that the prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam gave the entire
the entire militia,
if you will,
a one
basket of dates.
Now, it's not a little basket. It's a
big basket.
But they had to ration these dates.
The companions radiyallahu anhum later
narrated that
our ration was one date per man per day.
And we were so hungry
that when we would
finish the date,
one of the tabi'in that was listening to
this companion narrate this, he said,
"How did you survive?"
He said,
"When we finished eating the
date, the meat of the date,
we would continue to march and suck
on the pit of the dates until it
was more or less
dissolved, and then we would drink and
and follow that with water.
That was their ration."
And
their
leader that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam had appointed
was Abu Ubaidah ibn al-Jarrah, radi
[Arabic recitation]
Abu Ubaidah ibn al-Jarrah is one of
is one of what?
one of the 10
that were earmarked for paradise.
All right? Ahad al-Ashara.
And so,
as Allah had decreed it,
when they got and skirted up to the
shore, shoreline
of the Red Sea,
they
came upon a big, giant, washed up
dead
whale.
It was a giant whale. It was so big that
they were crawling inside of it.
All right?
And so,
they had never found a whale before.
And so, some of the companions were
hesitant
on whether or not it was permissible
to eat.
They later discussed it amongst
themselves and came to the
conclusion that it is permissible.
And so they sat there for
a couple of weeks camped out at that
whale
eating and cooking
and eating and cooking and taking the
whale's
fat and making lotion for their feet.
They was a spa for them, right?
And they were totally topped up
by this whale.
they didn't just use the whale oil
for for lotion, but they also used it to
put on their bows. They also used it
to put on the wood to treat the wood.
They also used it on their swords to
help with rust. They also used the
whale oil for lanterns, right?
it was just an abundance. It was a
goldmine.
And so
they had almost
an assembly line, a supply
chain
where some of them were inside and they
had gone in through one of the eyes and
they were just they had buckets that
they were filling with this nice fresh
whale meat and every day they were
eating to their fill.
And they took a bunch of this whale meat
home with them when they went back to
Medina.
And so when they arrived back in Medina,
the first order
of business was to
ask of the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam if what they had done was
correct.
That, you know, this had washed up on on
shore and it was already dead and we
used our best faculties to
you know, examine all the verses and
narrations that we know, but we came to
the conclusion that it was permissible.
Were we correct?
And so the prophet
told them that they were correct.
And he
took some of the meat for himself. So
I lay with him.
The point here
is that
any
animal
that resides primarily in the water.
Notice the wording, resides primarily
in the water.
So this will include amphibians
that reside primarily in the water.
Except frogs. Frogs are the only
amphibians which are impermissible to
eat.
Outside of that
it's open season. Any
fish
any dead or alive is permissible
to eat.
So
in this narration, we have two things
that our prophet teaches us. Number one
the water
of the sea is not only pure, but it is
extremely purifying.
That's number one.
And number two,
that anything
in the sea
even if it is dead is permissible to
eat. And this is mentioned in the Quran.
You will allow to Allah.
Which is probably the verse that the
companions had
used to come to this conclusion.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
[Silence]
Allah
the
catch of the sea is permissible for you
all
and the food of the sea is permissible.
And Ibn Abbas says what's meant here by
the food of the sea is the dead fish,
the dead of the sea.
So, that is enough for today. We'll
continue tomorrow insha'Allah.